the travel nightmare continues flights
canceled or delayed for thousands
Nationwide and officials are pointing
the finger at one airline in particular
Southwest we have Team coverage tonight
Victoria Saha tells us how this may
impact New Year's Eve Travelers but with
Ryan Matthey at the airport speaking
with frustrated Travelers right
[Music]
Vanessa it's thousands of canceled
flights leading to thousands of Tire
Travelers and you can see over my
shoulder here these are just some of the
hundreds on top of thousands of bags
that are outside Southwest baggage
offices and other places across the
property now 360 flights were canceled
yesterday it's close to 250 today and
the vast majority of these cancellations
coming from this Airport's biggest
Carrier Southwest
and I left Friday
Friday
what's today yeah hello traveling
troubles aren't letting up I don't know
when I'm gonna get home Karen Whitelaw
is one of thousands who can't get
through to Southwest National Flight
problems led her to try rebooking her
flight to New York until later next week
but she has to do it in person because
when she tried canceling her original
flight remotely I'm sure the site
crashed I tried through the app then I
tried online then I asked my daughters
who are more tech savvy to help yeah and
they couldn't do it they're not even
offering to see if they could switch it
themselves they're not even looking
Ernest Jones is trying to get his
nine-year-old son back to his mom in
Texas I really want to get home although
his flight isn't canceled the increased
rebookings and seemingly unreliable
Staffing means there's no room for
unaccompanied minors we got to try to
make it work some way somehow or get his
mom to fly here and buy another ticket
to a different Airline so that's two
tickets that's about another 800
probably at this time last minute most
of us are going to file a claim and even
if Flyers make it through their luggage
might not as Southwest representative
have said 3 000 unclaimed bags sit on
property do you even know if it's here
right now no I have no idea the line
that I was standing in is to just get
into baggage claim to speak to a person
close toiletries I have prescriptions
you know just think about the things
that we travel with every day
[Music]
people that you see here thousands or
hundreds I should say rather have been
coming through all day looking for their
bags the Southwest representative we
spoke to says that they are offering
flight vouchers uh some refunds even
accommodations where they can but
Travelers say that is not enough that's
especially considering the days of work
and vacation that they've already lost
because of all of this the CEO for
Southwest they say that they've canceled
two-thirds of the flights Nationwide
that they normally scheduled for today
through tomorrow reporting live at Harry
Reid International Ryan Matthey a news
now